[Applause]
shadow home secretary yvette cooper
thank you madam deputy speaker
this is a shambles and it is shameful
and the home secretary has no one but
herself to blame
this is not and never has been a serious
policy and she knew that when she
chartered the plane
she knew that among the people she was
planning to send to rwanda on this plane
were torture and trafficking victims she
knew she didn't have a proper screening
process in place she knew that some of
them might be children so can she
confirm it was the home office itself
that withdrew a whole series of these
cases on friday
and yesterday because they knew there
was a problem with these cases that even
without the european court of human
rights judgment she was planning to send
a plane with just seven people on board
because she'd had to withdraw most of
the cases at the last minute
she knows that there is a lack of proper
asylum capacity in rwanda to make fair
decisions that as the unhcr
says they only normally deal with a few
hundred cases a year there's normally
only one eligibility officer who
prepares the cases and that's as well as
lack of interpreters or legal advice to
ensure fair decisions now she promised
there will be extra payments
to rwanda for each person that is
transferred presumably to pay for those
extra case workers or extra support but
she still refused to tell us
how much
so what is she hiding will she tell us
now how much she promised rwanda for
each of the people she was planning to
send yesterday and how many rwandan
refugees she promised to take in return
she knows that serious concerns have
been raised about rwandan restrictions
on political freedom on the treatment of
people who are lgbt on the fact that 12
refugees were shot by the authorities in
2018 for protesting against food cuts on
the fact that there have been afghan and
syrian asylum seekers returned by rwanda
and she knows that none of those
concerns have been addressed she knows
too that the policy will not work
we need action to tackle dangerous
criminal gangs who are putting lives at
risk
but she knows that her policies won't
achieve that and that is not their
objective because if it was she would
not have asked the national crime agency
whose job it is to target the criminal
gangs to draw up 20
staff cuts that is potentially a
thousand people being cut from the
organization that works to tackle the
gangs so can she confirm has she asked
the nca to draw up plans for staff cuts
if she was serious she would be taking
seriously the fact that the israel
rwanda deal ended up increasing criminal
people trafficking and smuggling and
that her plan risks making things worse
and if it was she would be working night
and day to get a better joint plan with
france to crack down on the gangs and to
stop the boat being put into the water
in the first place but she isn't because
her relationship with french ministers
has totally broken down if she was
serious about tackling illegal migration
illegal economic migration or cutting
the bills for people in hotels she would
be speeding up home office decision
making so refugees can get support and
those who aren't can be returned home
instead her decisions have totally
collapsed from 28 000 a year to just 14
000 decisions a year fewer than belgium
the netherlands never mind germany or
france and she's so badly failing to
take those basic decisions she is trying
to pay a country thousands of miles away
to take decisions for us instead how
shameful does that make us look around
the world
if our home office cannot take those
basic decisions she knew about problem
after problem with her policy she knows
this is unworkable unethical and won't
stop the criminal gangs but yet she
still went ahead and spent half a
million pounds chartering a plane she
never expected to fly she still went
ahead and wrote a 120 million pound
check to rwanda with a promise of more
to come and she still went ahead because
all she really cares about is picking
fights and finding someone else to blame
this isn't a long-term plan it is a
short term
everyone can see it it's not a serious
policy it's shameless posturing and she
knows it it's not building consensus
it's just pursuing division it is
government by gimmick it's not in the
public interest it's just in their
political interest and what are they
prepared to trash along the way people's
lives our basic british values of
fairness decency and common sense and
the reputation of our nation our country
is better than this we have a long
tradition of hard work and stepping up
to tackle problems not to offload them
to tackle the criminal gangs who put
lives at risk and to do right by
refugees that is what she should be
doing now and not these shambles that is
putting our country to shame
[Applause]